what's up everybody it's your boy Travis
Hunter back with another Banger you know
what time it is we back
though how everybody day going hope you
having a good day blessed day your boy
back first thing we got is the game vers
Utah recap so let's go ahead and get
into
it yeah man I just wish was doing that
the whole game but star he came out
there played
great you know two ain't play he was
hurt but star came out Dam play great
man he seen a one-onone match up he took
advantage of
it like I've been saying it's like a
9010 ball it's like a
9010 chance I'm GNA get the ball I mean
catch the ball when it's getting thrown
to me man you know how that go just
throw me the ball I'm G make plays I'mma
make it
happen easy catch why they keep robbing
you of TV I don't know man they just
don't like me or something
I ended up getting me late TD though I
still got my touchdown even though
that's like the third one I scored of
that day and neither one of them was
down uh out of bounds whatever they was
saying
so
touchdown that greedy was
crazy this right here was a catch I
don't care what nobody say that's a
catch bro never loost control of the
ball never lost control of
it it's a catch it's a
catch it was a catch never lost control
of the ball look at the ball never lost
control of it never lost control of the
ball but guess what they did no you lost
control you have full possession but you
know that's how it be when you not at
your home uh home field so that's how it
was we was at our home field so most of
the things we did that was good that we
would have got at our home field we
didn't get because it was
away but yeah had multiple touchdowns
call
back yeah I was sick I was sick the
whole week I didn't practice not one day
last week uh the last game I was sick
the whole week but I still went on a
trip with a team and I ended up playing
and I played great
so yeah I didn't play I didn't practice
I I wasn't able to uh I didn't practice
I wasn't even at the facility for I
stayed home in the bed just sick all
week just Hoten away from the world the
whole week and I still went out there
and played did my thing still did what I
had to do but yeah good to show you that
I'm just on the next level didn't
practice not one time that week went out
and still played we didn't finish the
season the way we wanted to but hey try
to do the best we could I Bo out 195 for
his first start ever me eight receptions
107 yards hey you passed me the ball bro
best believe I got two touchdowns taken
away from me so I supposed to be really
H felt like I had about
200 but you know they took him away from
me but it's all
good well are you coming back for
another year yes I have to I have a
choice
nah yeah you know I always do that I
always stay out there if you I got
Colorado stuff on travel or I me on Way
games home games I always stay out the
sign stuff so that's just me that's what
I do if you got the other team stuff on
not signing it sorry if you got my
jersey on definitely gonna get your St
signed so you ain't even got to worry
about it just wear that 12 Jersey I will
see you no matter where I'm at I will
see that number 12 Jersey
hey fell it was no quit in you man you
guys play your butt off you fall hard to
the very D in and I'm proud of you I'm
I'm absolutely proud of you make sure
you give your coaches your coaches a hug
give them some love um teammates make
sure you really let them
know thank you and God bless you pray
for everybody inside this locker room as
as well as equipment man the doctors and
everybody that's a part of this one this
is truly a gift man that's why we call
it the president and we're here you have
nothing you have nothing to hang your
head down with one thing about the the
Bold or faithful you gave them all hope
and they cannot wait till tomorrow and
the next day the next day to put to see
what we build I'm proud of y'all man I'm
not disappointed whatsoever I know we
could have done much better but I'm
unbelievably proud of each and every one
of you guys coaches included as well as
staff yeah cuz BR this you know it was a
hard season for us but we still managed
to make it out did what we had to do
what we did what we could do
but hey man it was hard for us this
season just a group of men coming
together that we never seen before at
for one year basically and just the win
four
games that's improve we improveed for us
I mean next year best winning more than
four games coming different next year
for
sure all right now it's time for the
full year uh stats let me see them
things uh 31 tackles three interception
five pass deflection 721 receiving yards
five
touchdowns hey that ain't bad to look be
out for three games now three
weeks ain't bad for three weeks man 300
more yards I already had a
th hey next year going to be a better
year though just wait on it next year
it'll be a better year I should have had
way more receiving yards this year that
uh I had but I I lost three games
couldn't played three games yeah and
cheated a few more
touchdowns but it's all good know how
that
go BR put had eight touch well seven
touchdowns but it's all
good still got 721 yards to missed three
games that ain't bad I got some cooking
though I'mma cook some up for y'all next
year all right next we got uh
overreaction and out of
reaction yall know how that go y know
how we
play
did hand is definely like not
overreaction that boy grab that
one that was a good catch that was a
great
catch
snag
next def is a cheat Cod I seen this one
hand grab right here
gray
catch gray
catch not over reaction
next yeah a plus play that's a good play
calling
IQ not overreaction it's a great play
call nothing else you can do by that
nothing short of a miracle you right I
seen this
play I know this is fourth and go fourth
and
31 and they got this
y not over reaction nothing nothing
short of America
boy
that's what happened when arban play bro
something always something crazy always
happen when they play each
other that was a great catch next bro
next
but I can't be a test that's the same
thing that happened to me
bro if y'all call this attest is
wrong I mean he is down but he didn't
have possession basically what you're
saying he got a finish possession
through the ground right exactly what
they said to
me oh reaction not a touchdown bro I
don't believe it's a
touchdown that was a pick yeah I know it
was interception of the year I seen this
yes not over reaction definitely
interception of the year but he caught
that jump behind his
back all right let's see these Stacks
man a g lie them Stacks go crazy only
finish year with two interceptions it's
crazy 43 total touchdowns it's crazy but
it's definitely wide open for them
quarterbacks boy if I a Miss three games
I will be up there who I'm
picking is got to beat J uh jadden
Daniels bro he got to win it not a
overreaction it's definitely wide open
what we got next bro what's Wild for
this J be going
crazy
he made him miss
it n he's wild for that though not
overreaction he's definitely wild for
that bro what is he doing why are you
doing that right now Tom Brady told no
lie yeah he's right though there a lot
of soft playing going on in the leag BR
best blurs oh all right we doing we
doing uh next up is spin on a spin on a
blur it's different from what we did uh
the last couple weeks yeah you can start
it we going to pick the best blurs of
the season
so let's get right into
it all ah I hurt myself blur
Championship let's
see get to it let's get right into
it that's definitely top tier bro that's
one that's definitely one
bro that's definitely
won
ah ah see his was for a
touchdown nah he a grab it one hand
fully bro it had to bounce around first
nah but that was luck yeah bro the first
one was the the best one bro the first
one he win
bro right there he
win
next
I'm top tier
bro I'm top tier bro that's on two
people bro ain't just one person you
bluring you bluring two people at one
time but one hand is crazy blur is
crazy that's a good
blur
that's a good blur but I was in front of
that that was on two people bro and then
I broke my
leg blur see I'm telling you bro that
two people blur is different
bro two people blur is different bro
junk is different
bro
he did just teat just snag that
[__] D two people blur is different
though bro he did just snagged in what's
his name
though it's a good blur
though but two two people blur is just
different bro I almost broke my whole
inkle
BR that's different too
now this is different that's not even a
blur though CU there was nobody there
it's just a great
catch it's definitely Michigan the
Michigan one definitely
top
blur definitely Michigan
bro but if I had to do it bro it would
be that old miss
one that old miss one is a good blur Old
Miss is definitely Second Blur bro I'm
the first blur can't get any better than
me bro almost broke my leg
bro that
one it's it's uh the Old Miss second I'm
first this one is third and the last one
is fourth then it's me bro I almost lost
my
leg see look bro I almost broke my leg
bro almost broke my leg
bro imagine almost about to break your
leg and you still catching the ball come
on bro
difficult you already catching over two
people and then you about to break your
[__]
ah hey give me
that give me that through that
[Music]
lane all right we call this football
playoff pitcher getting
close getting into a
closer all right basically bro we just
going to build a perfect team with the
teams left in the mix so
quarterback we got Georgia Michigan
Washington Florida State Oregon Alabama
and
Texas quarterback I would goes with
would
be I'm G say Jordan Travis because that
boy he could throw that he could throw
the dime
he throw the ball in the dime he can run
get out the pocket he's going to be
smart with the ball he going to score no
matter what so quarterback Jordan Travis
running back Oregon got a good running
back but Florida State got four good
running
backs they don't have uh LSU on here
it's only Georgia Michigan Washington
Florida State Oregon Alabama
Texas Michigan got a running back
running back Michigan running back yeah
I forgot his
name Blake yeah
Blake yeah Blake K Michigan got a good
running
back receiver uh what's Oregon
receiver Troy something number 11 that
boy
fast Troy Franklin
yeah Troy flanking right there
receiver oine did y'all not just see how
Alabama o line was just holding up it's
definitely gonna
be Washington got a go o line too
though Washington o line we fix that
front seven fix that front
seven uh we gonna do yeah we're gonna do
Washington oine who got a good dline you
know Georgia always got a good dline but
we need Georgia head
coach we need Texas is fan
base no we need Alabama head coach
Georgia defense we going to pick Georgia
defense in line for
defense head coach Nick sa
Alabama in
Texas fan
base wow what an
imagination FSU dine I know but I
already use I already used FSU
quarterback W list W list okay
okay okay okay okay okay y'all messing
with the list all right yeah you can't
take SSU
twice so I had took the quarterback
which I would use the quarterback the
quarterback was crazy to I always like
Jordan Travis though he was always good
to me I needed I need a organ receiver I
couldn't get
Bucky you know you one time
Texas Best Line fan base so w all
right Michigan all over I already use
Michigan running
back can't use him twice only can use
him once I know I could use romier but I
need they uh I need a I need a what's
the name toy Franklin from Oregon that
boy be
moving can I guard that
boy I know bck dog but I need his
receiver
Keon colan couldn't use him because I
used the
quarterback no here junior no Ohio State
not in the mix because they lost I know
I ain't gonna make everybody
happy well I'mma pick BR B at he's a
tight end a no tight end on here all
right next what we got
next me St what y'all talking about all
right m l l we thinking how St was GNA
go into Michigan and win that game
yeah y'all lost Ohio State lost Michigan
won so chat y'all lost y'all two and oh
three and three I
won uh
bo college football playoffs who you
think should be at College uh who should
be at number four for college football
playoffs Florida State Oregon Texas
Alabama
pick who y'all got Oregon on Florida
State
okay Oregon winning then all right I
guess Oregon win so it said Oregon
should be on number four spot he if
y'all lose that's your problem that's
not my fault they say orgon okay we
gonna see if orgon slips in
there pause all right next before we uh
and y'all know our season is done so
it's a a lot ahead of us still still got
another year expectations for next year
just go out and
ball try to come the highest draft pick
I can ball out try to win some with my
team let's go out with my new
team well not my new team but my team
and just win as many games as we can get
to where we want to be try to get to
National Championship try to get a bowl
game just try to get everything we
didn't get this year so that's all I got
for y'all next year hey it's going to be
a better year for me better year for the
team so if you're fans of us stay with
us we got y'all we won't let y'all down
next year it's your host Travis Hunter
with 12
talks
and we got a actually we we got another
uh what's podcast next Monday so next
Tuesday yeah next Tuesday so may sure
you come in next Tuesday we're gonna
talk about the games so yeah that's the
last one
next Tuesday so see y'all next Tuesday
make sure y stay blessed up prayed up
stay safe love y'all thanks for
supporting me suppor and bleach your
report
and see you what want to be it's your
host Travis son with t talks and we
out all
right all
right